[Music]
about a decade ago now wow time flies i
was doing the apple commercials with
john hodgman who played the pc friend of
the show a very good friend friend of
mine and the show uh it was the get a
mac campaign and one of our favorite
things to do in between what they call
setups when they're setting up the
camera a little industry term uh we used
to love to entertain ourselves and
one of the bits we would do was we'd do
fake commercials for other things
so like whatever you were holding or
eating but his favorite uh product the
product we would do most often because
it was what he was drinking most of the
time it was like john's one
request that he would request this
product to be he was like jlo
yeah yeah what did she request didn't
doesn't she need like lilac mystic
all these demands or am i thinking of uh
mariah carey oh i think mariah carey uh
i have a feeling that that's a confused
icon yeah yeah you get diva confusion
uh i think jlo j.lo from
i think has a reputation for being that
that way but i think she's really like i
met her briefly she seemed really down
to earth wow sorry to yeah defensive
payload proposal well i'm just because
i'm a jailer myself so oh that's why but
defensively
don't spread that [ __ ] about it what
happened to the story anyway oh sorry
right i'm telling you story
uh i don't know let's get into it
life could be a dream life could be a
dream
you're listening to life is short i am
your diet dr pepper
hating host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
and with me is always he's squinting
right he now he's wondering if maybe we
should re-record that no i'm wondering
why you hate diet dr pepper i just don't
like the aftertaste you tasted it yeah
yeah of course john drank it all the
time it was around it all the time it
was such a weird specific thing for him
to like i'm surprised you don't like it
i'm surprised you like it so much it's
got that weird deity after i see i i
disagree it's been years since i've had
it but i think what i do remember is
that it was known to be
a diet soda that tasted like the regular
version
well i remember loving grape remember
schweppes grape ginger ale oh that was
good you know that's
it was dry grape and uh strawberry right
no raspberry raspberry right yeah it was
and then they had a cranberry one then
they started getting crazy the grape was
better than the raspberry oh much yeah
it was like yeah it's delicious there's
a little dime-a-tappy my point is i love
that so much that soda that i think mom
once got the diet version and i even
tolerated that
just to get the grape taste um why are
we talking about about
diet dr pepper well i don't know well
this is probably our most roundabout
segway and bear with me for a second dr
pepper was a
a different brand i don't think was the
name brand version of this i think
that's incorrect there was a similar uh
type of soda called mr pibb still exists
i think uh
i don't i think i looked it up recently
and
yeah and i think mr pibb well you're
gonna want to fact check me on this
because i think it was around
the same time as dr pepper i don't know
who came first so it's unfair i think
of of mr pibb to say that it was
a knockoff version of dr pepper i think
anyway mr pibb was their colleagues they
were yeah it was the less uh maybe the
less educated of the that's pretending
in that family well i always used to
think that that dr pepper that mr pibb
was the one that like didn't go to
medical school
and like that his brother like joe
pepper that's funny i ended up going um
but uh it always used to make me laugh
that name mr pibb i don't know why i
just thought it was a funny name and
when we did dodgeball
back in the day um
with with the great cast uh i really
loved that cast uh there was a character
called gordon and gordon gordon was
having trouble he was kind of like
powerless in his family dynamic and
he was going through a separation if you
remember the movie and uh i i always
thought that it would be funny to call i
don't know i always wanted to call a
character mr pibbs so i started calling
i pitched it to the director rawson and
he
i think he liked it so i started calling
gordon's character in that movie mr pibb
because i was younger i was a young high
school student in that movie and i
thought i would be deferential to an
older an adult
and i had respect for so i called him mr
pibb and in the credits to this day if
you look it's gordon pibb
thanks to yours
very proud of that i i don't know if i i
guess i do need to remind you of this
but you recently co-wrote an entire
movie and right you named half the
characters in that at least
and you gave them last names but
dodgeball is a classic
that's a bigger feather for your cap at
this well the lady the manner hopefully
one day will be a classic who knows uh
but anyway so who played gordon pibb in
that movie
our guest today that's right our guest
today is i think the
ultimate character actor uh one of my
favorite actors and just um an
all-around
really interesting funny wonderful
person steven root brilliant actor
brilliant actor he's a legend and steven
and i
this is god as if this episode didn't
sound braggy enough with all my name
dropping and that i met jlo once and i
did dodgeball uh steve and i have worked
together so many times it's hard i don't
remember all of the things we did but i
was
we've done many things your paths have
crossed many times he played my dad in a
movie that probably no one saw goes
raising genius uh and then we did
episodes of king of the hill together we
did idiot we did a lot of things
together he's such a good actor that
legendary filmmakers treat him like
their favorite actor you know and they
put him in everything like mike they're
fans of and the cone brothers that's how
you know he's amazing yeah you know a
legend you can call an actor a legend
when legends are fans of them exactly um
that's a much more concise way and uh
when's the first time you saw stephen i
think my introduction to him was i don't
think it was news radio i think it was
probably office space uh yeah or
seinfeld oh seinfeld right so on yeah he
plays the guy that kramer he's the bank
manager when kramer doesn't get a proper
hello at the bank that's right um but
he's most people i would say know him
from uh office space he plays milton
uh have you seen my stapler oh my god
he's so good in that and yes now i'm
gonna do something with that because
he's done everything
he's such a chameleon he's one of those
guys where and whenever i'm around him
whenever he gets recognized it's a
version of
hey i i know you they he triggers
something in people but they don't
always know exactly you know it's hard
to put their finger on because he's so
different in everything you see he
doesn't get out he's checking and if you
don't know his name if you google him
right now you will i guarantee you you
will immediately know who he is yeah
there'll be a million different things
there'll be a bunch of this reaction oh
right
and that
oh my god and that he's that guy let's
hear from him okay here he is the uh
chameleon the great my friend my dear
friend steven roo life could be a dream
sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming we'll
meet
[Music]
i know you made your mark as
some a more beta certainly milton in
office space is the epitome of beta
characters but um i i have forgotten all
the
all the great film work you did before
that for the the couple years leading up
to that and
and you were cast mostly i noticed as
you played detectives or more
hard-boiled
uh
authoritarian uh a little a little heavy
not heavies but a little heavy boston
and stephen i'm really interested in um
because i don't think i know this uh i
know that your film debut which i've
seen every time it's on i look for you
uh crocodile dundee ii
yes yes my i
i think my credit was
toilet
classy so you knew right away you were
going to have a classy career
but that was weird because
i i was in new york at that time and i
was
still doing theater mostly and
but i got in these two films that people
i mean a lot of people saw crocodile in
d2 it wasn't as big as the first one but
then i got ghost after that
and that was
that's right you played a cop and ghost
you know yeah yeah and both both out of
new york weirdly crocodile dundee ii is
a movie that
i don't know if i just have it's on my
radar so i notice it more but it seems
to be on a lot it's not a lot it's when
he goes to la right
yeah um and how does something like that
happen like i
you've been doing such great theater
work is that just as simple as we have
an audition for this thing and you end
up just getting it is it very much yeah
just like most most of our your stuff
and my early stuff is just
your agent trying to get you into film
auditions as opposed to theater or right
or
uh daytime tv you know which i'd also
done and then stephen when you do a
couple of those roles in big movies like
that
similar similar type roles are what are
you are you at that point just thinking
i just want to keep getting jobs that
this pays it pays the in away theater
doesn't i want to just keep getting
whatever film jobs i can or are you
think are you at all afraid of
um i mean this sounds ridiculous to say
because you're known now as such a
chameleon but at the time was there any
fear of
being type cast as no not not at that
point we're just trying to feed your
family you know
because i had uh
i had had uh a kid so you know we we're
just looking for jobs just like
everybody and uh
i was i was happy to have anything yeah
you know i think i played
uh this uh jeans ebert uh the bigger one
siskel and ever i remember doing um
an industrial where i was playing uh
roger ebert and
and they gave us just scads of dialogue
which we had to put on teleprompters and
and i was eating a huge submarine
sandwich it was job time yep it was time
to just get a job was that the weirdest
one
yeah that's probably the weirdest
industry
well i don't know if you're playing
roger you're playing him
that's weird very weird did you have to
do
him i mean did you do an approximation
yeah i kind of did him but there's i i
would love to have seen him but i'd love
to see that i wonder if that's floating
around
have you done it have you done anything
industrial type of corporate stuff that
you
see done but not
not that i recall i remember auditioning
for them they were very strange having
to show people how to do
instructional videos i remember
auditioning for something like that um
playing a student who couldn't figure
something out there was a math learning
thing but you know stephen when i
started out there was a lot i was doing
a lot of voiceovers that that it was the
late 90s early 2000s so that that what's
up bro that like slacker guy was cool
and i
so i got a lot of that stuff but um
when you and and of course you do
science a show like seinfeld must have
been
that was before news radio it was that
no it was right there it was
jerry had come over and done one of ours
oh uh and and and he just said do you
want to come over and do this you know a
little bank manager thing with
with us and i said yeah of course oh
it's so good it's the one where kramer
doesn't he felt like he wasn't giving a
proper hello
greeting
at the bank and and
yeah and you have to yeah you become the
final say uh was that was being a part
of that because i it's my favorite show
and i just i love it so much i feel like
i know was it um i get people i get
people more people now mentioning that
than almost anything sometimes really
especially when
oh yeah absolutely and my friend uh
brian reddy who's the high talker yes
he's great that's right i met him
through you i met i remember that you
introduced me to him at that play uh
gets more from that one little thing
it's just crazy
yes yeah dan it's dan
that's right i remember meeting him and
being actually kind of taken aback that
his voice was that was quite deep
yeah deep and stubborn
that's right
um and so then so you're doing and of
course uh news radio is a huge show
what but how did
did mike judge already know you before
office space i mean did he
do you have a relationship with him
in any way he had he had known through
my agents that i did southern stuff
uh-huh
southern stuff uh and i can't remember
whether it was voice over stuff and or
uh he'd seen you know cross the fire
these other southern
you know movies that i had done yeah
but he didn't know that i did southern
stuff and and and called me in for that
reason interesting so he was looking for
specific i see i didn't know milton even
had a southern
well it's texas you know it's it's it's
um right it's not it's not georgia
southern it's
you know it's it's something different
and
he he tried me out for dale first which
i didn't feel comfortable with it uh but
as soon as we could find a character
dumber than that i was perfect
and he but it was a character he had
already milton he had done the shorts
on snl i think um or they
and did
did he want did he have a very specific
the way you you talked about gary cole
at london playing lundberg how he had a
very specific um
voice in mind for lundberg it was based
on a character mike knew did he have
that for milton
he did uh he had done a two-minute
pencil sketch of it uh for when we were
going over to
uh read it for fox
and he was gonna he was gonna do milton
he was gonna do milton in the reed and
at the last minute while we're walking
over he said no you do it
he was gonna you were gonna he was gonna
have you do dale
yeah he no no no i'm talking about uh
office space he was gonna ha he was
gonna read no oh oh and for the read for
fox i was doing the uh
the hypno the guys that get hypnotized i
was doing one of the bobs
i was i was doing you know a plethora of
little roles he was gonna do milton i
mean at the last minute he said no
i want to hear it you do it i said well
thanks for the prep and he showed me the
two-minute pencil sketch
and he he had done a version of that
voice he said do something like that and
that's why i did something like that it
was it's really quite a list
i put a lisp in it that he didn't have
that's right
i don't know what else that's right
there's something reptilian almost about
yet with with the lisp
without it even those big eyes and
uh could you even see could you see
anything out of those glasses
no uh we had to have contact
to be able to see through the glasses oh
my god and and then because i
because of both of those things i had no
depth perception at all so when i ever
had to reach for the stapler or
or anything i had to practice it before
oh my god
i couldn't see how far away it was so
you had to get like muscle memory
yeah yeah
so when you when you see me reaching for
it it's i don't know where the [ __ ] it
is
and did he and those in those scenes
where you're just
your voice kind of drowns out it's so i
mean obviously brilliantly directed and
acted but did he explain did he have you
just riff it seems like you're just
riffing about something did he say oh
just be be annoyed by something or
uh yeah he would a couple of times in
the thing i mean there was no dialogue
in the cake scene he said just come in
and and
and be unhappy that you don't get caught
that was all pretty much of an improv
when they're passing the cake you have
to keep passing it milton now
yeah
yeah
it's no cake
no so i just just ripped on
on whatever that was but there wasn't a
lot of
there there wasn't a lot of huge
ad-libbing in that thing and it was
pretty tightly structured
and uh but he would let people do it i
mean
um
not gonna you're not gonna work here
anymore
that was uh
oh no kidding oh it's a great line bob's
yeah oh and you know john john again go
for hours yeah for hours so
do you know i mean this is probably such
a boring question to answer but
and i
sometimes people ask about dodgeball did
you know it was going to be a
well received and something that people
talked about for years but but was that
the case with office space
you're doing a b movie comedy for mike
that that was mike's first directing job
and he said that's gonna be a blast
but you know
didn't expect anything out of it other
than to have fun with your friends
because we you know we all know each
other yeah and from that a lot of people
from king of the hill and other people
i've worked with that's true that's
right in fact it must have been yeah
that whole group that was going over
that table read most of them were
probably just coming from
absolutely we just came from one of
king's tailories absolutely wow um
and how did you do you did three or four
i did yeah i think so um he would have
me do
miscellaneous voices usually kind of
younger punky type uh
i'm forgetting i mean i it was just so
fun to play around and
you know he's as you know he's not a big
laugher so
i i always feel like i need um
that validation whenever i was trying
out some of the voices and
but then i once you get to know him you
realize like he likes you'll know when
he likes something it's just he's just
not effusive
he'll say like oh that's funny or like
yeah exactly you know if you get a you
gotta yeah
that's pretty good
yeah yeah totally like you talking about
ad living in idiocracy i remember ad
libbing
a little bit and he would come back in
and tell me
the things that he liked you know like
oh i like it when you said yeah do that
again that was that was really
good that's how he directed very much
off his face i like this when you did
this ah this is funny i do do people
when they do recognize you from that is
it do they just say where's your stapler
do they just say things like that about
the stapler is it usually stapler
related yeah it's it's the stapler guy
you know they don't never really
remember the name right because this
film was 20 years old now it's
1999
1999 crazy and steve you were talking
about uh
doing southern being able to do the
different variations was that see i
didn't know that you had traveled around
so much as a kid i didn't realize that
you had that very nomadic upbringing
very much yeah like an army brat yeah
huh does it what do you think
did your ear just become
honed
based on from that from from traveling
around i think like a lot of people you
know you either have a good ear that you
can replicate things or you don't so you
have a perfect one because you created
um
impressions and just voices in general
but i i think i have a decent enough
year that i can reproduce
and uh
get get
get the dialect and then keep it for a
while keep it in memory bank and use it
again and certainly the coen brothers
have asked you to
to call upon that that skill and
how how specific are they i mean because
you've done such different characters
some some of whom have extreme accents
or very you know
quite thick yeah
how specific do they get with with notes
like that about
dialect
dialect uh not as much because they
probably hired you because they know you
could do that but they they they
i think they
their
finest hour is casting you know they
they cast
exactly who they want to see but who can
also act
and uh and since they storyboard down to
the nth degree
they get exactly what they want uh we
talked about this on an earlier thing
but they they do let you play
you know after they've gotten what they
want they'll give you another another
chance to just do something
off the wall and maybe they'll use it
maybe they won't but
they're at least collaborative in that
respect and i mean not at least it's
very collaborative in terms of that it's
great
and both joel and ethan yeah do it in
different ways
they do it in different ways they're one
brain but they they communicate
differently
i got i just love them so much i love
your work with them uh
all we're talking about all these
character parts all these extreme did
you ever harbor
ambitions or desires to be
a quote-unquote leading man was that
something that you were or were you just
more comfortable as a character actor i
i've i've always been comfortable as a
character actor because you can come in
and dive bomb something and then go out
totally and then do something else i
mean because i've always wanted to do
different stuff
but at some point in your career at
least in mine and people that i know
that
you have to educate the casting
directors more than anything else to say
look yeah i can i can do comedy i can do
the crazy guy but i can also do
a villain and i can do
you know straight
detective or whatever
so that
after i had done
news radio and another uh that come for
a couple of years that wasn't very good
i mean that's all i was getting offered
was you know kind of bad sitcom so i
stopped uh doing that
uh and turning down sitcom rolls and and
waited
until i could audition
for
or get get uh offers for other stuff so
that i waited for west wing and i waited
for
you know stuff like that
and would you hear from agents like well
they're looking for somebody a little
bit more serious they're looking would
you get that feedback and then at that
point you say
i i'd rather i'd like to just show them
yeah i'd i i'd rather show you yeah
because
obviously you haven't seen this and
you're not thinking of me this way
so uh i did that a lot in the in the
early 2000s when when you were doing a
lot of voice over stuff i was turning
down comedy to do
um uh more serious
interesting and and then along with that
okay yes i was a little a little
conflicted about doing dodgeball because
like that's kind of stuff i was turning
down but it was too funny a script into
too much fun to do i i knew i would want
to do it yeah it was such a good script
it was um i think it was called
underdogs when i first got it when we
got it and we did that was it i think so
underdogs and it was uh
i know or maybe not or i think so but
then they kept changing i don't know if
you remember the like um the subtitle
was always uh
based on the memoirs of uh
something somebody ridiculous you know
like
right a carrot top or somebody like that
it wasn't that but it was uh and so i
knew you know just from the title page
that
it it the tone was going to be absurdist
and
whoever wrote it was really funny and
didn't take themselves too seriously and
uh it was just such a i mean that's
that's what the experience felt like um
to me although then you reminded me the
other day of
some of those dodgeball sequences some
of the training montages were really
people are going to make fun of us for
saying this but so exhausting
they were brutal yeah but especially for
an older older guy um doing it with a
lot of younger guys but you knew it was
going to be great fun rosten was was
great and uh
you know it's fun yeah
speaking of speaking of the uh what what
it was called i remember the first
draft of the pilot of news radio was
called the office
no kidding yeah and i've got it i kept
it because nobody believes me but it was
oh that's funny and was that what that
was quite a pedigree right were that was
that james burroughs it was somebody big
they were big people yeah jimmy b
directed the first nation
he kind of created
the jimmy james character along with
paul as we were auditioning it started
out as kind of a regular you know
[ __ ] kind of weird boss but
i i wanted to do it more and more bent
and and he wrote it more and more ben in
that way until we got to networking he
was pretty bent but
but how fun
because i i was surprised when i met you
and we had met we were talking about a
movie we did before dodgeball but i was
surprised to learn how
different you were than the characters
that i had seen you play i mean you i'm
sure a lot of people have had that
reaction to you because you have such
indelible these characters were so
indelible but but like you said real
they were kind of they're [ __ ]
not to reduce it to that
um
yeah yeah i i at that point i was really
loving doing comedy and and and playing
just
you know i i didn't want to do straight
comedy i wanted to do
stuff like galaxy quest yeah you know
which that is that you're a hero of mine
from that movie uh and all those people
in there and sam and everybody else it's
just so great it's so so
stuff i wanted to do yeah yeah and but
so dodgeball felt a little
you made an exception because it was
funny and there's good people but but
was it um
was the thought process well this is
this is another kind of silly goofy
comedy as opposed to you mentioned
galaxy quest like a straighter comedy
that might you know
uh no i i just uh
as
i'm doing now i i i really go on script
is the script good
are the people in it do you want to work
with them and
that's that's it ah okay
and you had i didn't realize you left
you left college to go to broadway to do
something on broadway
uh
no i i left
college to go to the national
shakespeare company in new york
which was a bus and truck a 12-person
company a bus and truck that did
shakespeare
for nine months out of the year all over
the united states just like i had moved
all over the united states i was back
going through all these states playing
junior colleges doing othello and as you
like it it's so funny my older brother
did the same thing he did it for i don't
remember how long quite some time and
in the in the van i mean they would yeah
like it's yeah we had a we had a 63
trail always bus oh my god and four
genies that you know
made a stage and curtains and i think
our only scenery was a you know a step
ladder that went up and down and then we
did everything around that wow
it was the best training you could get
because you could do a 5 000 seat house
at west point and that's a show that you
have to really yeah
and then you do a
junior college cafeteria and that's a
different show even though it's the same
show yeah so it was the best best
training i could have gotten and we're i
mean you're talking about a fellow and
as you like it and so this shakespeare
was were these audiences high school
kids were they a receptive audience were
they um
they were because they they came in
expecting you know to see this really
boring shakespeare stuff and we were
it's 1976 we all had long hair
beards and we were these hippies doing
shakespeare in iowa i was like
what what
um they were always receptive after the
show and wanted to
talk to us about it and and wondered how
we got into that oh wow and and so you
then
just were doing i mean it was all
theater in the beginning it was all for
for how long
wow yeah and that was from when i got
out of col when i left college in 76
and we did the shakespeare company 76
through 79
and then
the early 80s i was doing theater all up
and down the
east coast wow yeah you had mentioned i
said i was from i told you where i was
in connecticut
yeah playhouse yeah
and all those all those things of the
algonquin circuit longworth
yeah long wharf yeah yeah in fact that's
where fran
frannie mcdormand that i met
uh doing all my sons at the long wharf
she was the girl oh my
god
and and she and joel
had just gotten together this is like 88
87 and they were just doing bloodstone
oh in 88 oh my god yeah with that wow my
god i love that movie
so the cohens knew you i didn't realize
that they knew you through francis
mcdormand then well they didn't really
but they they i think they knew of me
you know they
we didn't really know each other i mean
franny and i knew each other because we
did the play but
i didn't really know joel's except to
see this tall dark-haired guy with her
every once in a while well he at least
had seen i've seen you in plays and
stuff and uh
that's interesting but but how would you
ever isn't that funny i mean you look
back at it now and it like you connect
the dots but like how would you ever
have known that he was going to become
you know a guy like that
and i think the first audition i did for
them was oh brother anyway i don't think
he remembered me really i'm sure that
i'm sure that i look maybe he did he
didn't say anything about it but you
must have worked with i mean francis
mcdormand on
a bunch of those i think uh she must
have run into her over the years
yeah absolutely absolutely she and maura
tierney are good friends
and and
so they're it's all one big
you know when you get you get to a
certain age the the the talent pool
shrinks to the point of
people who are still doing it yes you
know because there's a lot of brilliant
people who are no longer doing it yeah
just because
revive
the erratic
you know lifestyle and pay and
everything else like that
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
one of those people i wanted to ask you
about i've never had occasion to ask you
about was um phil hartman who
i
i i when i was growing up i just he was
one of my favorites he was uh
yeah just a
brilliant actor and
i know you got to work with him so i
mean intimately
for quite some time what was that what
was that like what was he like i i'm
just so curious about him
he was
you know he
he at the very beginning of us doing
news radio he had just come off of
saturday night live
and there were two different scenarios
for him one was fighting tooth and nail
and
to get a skit on saturday night live and
and news radio was the phone page could
throw in a line and that would be fine
we don't we didn't care so
when he got to our set he was still
thinking
you know yeah that that's my bed you
can't use that yeah i'm i'm doing it
it's like when phil phil phil it's
going for the gold going for the show we
don't give a [ __ ] who
comes up with the line
it took them i think about a full year
to get that huh
and go oh okay well everybody can be
funny with everybody i see okay that's
so interesting steve i was talking
yesterday uh two or two days ago i was
talking to
david kechner and kechner had been on
snl for one year and he said um
i've spoken other people on the show
about and
this is this is the consensus so far is
that it was that environment uh snl it
was it was very competitive and you
really had to fight to get your stuff on
and it did breed the sense of
competition so that doesn't surprise me
at all uh
yeah and we were so the opposite of that
i mean dave you know had come from kids
in the hall whatever you know and uh
whatever works worked and i'd come from
theater whatever works work andy
came from mars and whatever
no and and the rest of us you know vicky
lewis uh
had just come off uh she wasn't was she
inside
yeah she did a signed vote but she also
did the tim tim's the tool man show oh
home improvement
home improvement
yeah yeah yeah which i had done as well
so she'd just come off for recurring on
that so we were all just recurring
actress yeah
you know pretty much
oh weird and joe rogan too right
logan too rogan was on some kind of
baseball comedy or something and that
didn't go but he had a huge quote so
he's like anything it's fine for me yeah
i'll be on this
weird news radio show but did you ever
talk to him it's funny now also to think
about
what who would have ever guessed that
he'd become this big uh
giant yeah personality yeah
smart and
very interesting yeah he really is the
last he was because he was naturally
good at and he's a natural actor he
couldn't do anybody but joe he couldn't
do anybody himself i don't think
or would he he wouldn't want to because
he was a stand-up
um but he was a naturally good
actor
great timing and uh
uh but what he's turned out to be was
just uh unbelievable yeah uh you had
said something interesting the other day
we were talking about um
getting into character how
rod had asked you how you do it and
and you mentioned wardrobe how important
that can be if you're wearing a
candy yeah
yeah wearing the right shoes can inform
a character uh i'm now thinking about
somebody like milton was milton
did did that have anything to do with
getting into milton was it being behind
that desk was it uh or was it more the
voice oh i think i got that guy just
literally from the two-minute pencil
sketch
so
that that was easy for me that wasn't
that wasn't from the outside in that was
like from the inside you know this
terrified person
i was staying at a job that he hadn't
been paid for for two years yeah
yeah i knew that guy
from the inside from this from the
script and from
just myself
my insecurity yeah you you said you had
you felt like that because i we were
talking about kids who do travel around
a lot when they're growing up and have
to
quickly make friends or assimilate
somehow
and you said you went the other way we
were talking about you go one of two
ways either you're the most gregarious
and you got to make your mark right away
or you
yeah
and you retreated kind of you were a
little bit more
yeah
yeah i became more of the book the book
guy the comic guy
the the shrinking violet guy but
interested in
archaeology and photography and all that
all that
stuff that was considered nerdville yeah
you know when i was
yeah well but then how how did acting
happen steven how did because performing
to me
seems like it doesn't seem like somebody
who would then gravitate toward
performing
i don't yeah it
i i literally think a lot of it was
because i got to college and i got
stoned oh
and it kind of
and it kind of released me you know yeah
it kind of just released me to go
well i can i i don't i don't know
you know you do mushrooms a couple times
you go
well maybe i can do this
yeah but but it was literally a um
an extra credit class that put me as a
spear character in a show and then i
went i saw everything around me and went
i think this would be fun i think i want
i think i want to take a class in this
and then i took
took an acting class and then boom i
changed majors and that was it one
acting class it was was it do you
remember was it something specific that
really
broke it through for you was it was it
like a specific play or teacher yeah
there were women in the class
check please uh
yeah
no no it was it was just the whole
because everybody in con in college you
do you do everything you do props
you do everything and that was really
interesting to me i didn't it didn't
end up being a techie but i could have
but i but it was more fun to to go out
and and play well stephen you know it's
funny you mentioned that because i
always felt a little
um embarrassed to admit this
that i i started acting in high school i
i really fell in love with it then but i
started because yeah it's where the
girls were it's where um
i was too small to play sports except
for dodgeball i wasn't gonna make girls
anywhere else yeah no
um
and at that age it's really all i
thought
that's all i thought about and i always
i mean to hear you say it is comforting
but i remember
i think anybody our age were kind of shy
or whatever um it just gravitates to
you know if i can get it anywhere near
one would be awesome
yes it'd be so great and i'll wear
tights i'll prance around i'll do
anything
my first play i was a woodland nymph in
uh yeah into the woods they created a
chorus because i was so all the kids who
didn't get in got you know to we were
basically moving furniture around and um
in tights and little like little little
unitards but so i yeah i suffered that
in dignity yeah you're right just to be
near just to just be my first play was
the andorra where i was a minion of the
jew detector
the yellow poster
[Laughter]
terrible play directed terribly
everybody was terrible in it but it led
to you actually doing the second thing i
did which was shakespeare oh my god and
what what what play
romeo and timmy get the shrew oh wow
well who would you play in romeo you
could have you know and that led to guys
and dolls doing nicely nicely and that
and other great roles you know that you
could do in college that you couldn't do
outside probably the exact yeah the
theater kids um must have been they must
have been like who the hell is this all
of a sudden he's getting
the lead
he's this he goes from the spear carrier
to now he's doing nicely nicely
well there's there's a lot of politics
and
college theater
what college was this steve
university of florida oh right
and who uh was that were they doing well
at the time in football was that
football a big thing i know it's a huge
part of the school that was carlos
alvarez time uh it was
now we were we had a good good
quarterback and a good uh
wide out but that the rest of the team
not so much and i remember
i don't know if it was like this then
but i remember going there for the first
time in maybe the late 2000s you know
like 2008 or nine oh that was that was
tim tebow's team it was during tim
tebow's uh reign and in fact i remember
asking that all the kids that i was like
oh my god the girl because i never seen
so many the
girls every they were like
lining up at these bar i'd never seen so
many bars in a row these clubs like
packed i it was crazy gainesville i
thought oh there might be like a local
we had like one bar off camp two bars oh
no it's it's crazy
on game day it's insane insane it was
the swamp is really you know it's
rocking and it's a really fun place to
see a game because uh if you're the
opposing team you can't hear anything in
there yeah that's 100 000 people going
when you're on defense and it's it's
crazy yeah we were talking about how
much um what an advantage and
disadvantage that that some a lot of
teams don't have now with the lack of
those or at all at all yeah
you go yeah your home team is what 10
000 people like a seahawks game yeah 100
000 c stadium wow so you don't have any
advantage there really so steve how does
a kid like um a wallflower is so as you
say nerdy kind of comic book kid how
does
what is that transition like from
that guy to
your partying in gainesville at which
come to find out is the
is the epicenter of the like party
universe and um
how what is it is it is it dry is it
weed and
drugs and when i was there yeah it's
much got more corporate i mean it got a
lot um
it went from hippieville when i was
there in in 70 to 75 76 to
uh
getting to more more you know straight
straight-line corporate stuff but
there was always that in the background
in gainesville steve was this around the
time oh my god i'm remembering that
there was a wait we can cut this out and
i'm probably i hope i'm wrong there's a
serial killer a famous cereal
yeah
what is that that happened there at the
uh oh what's the name of the tower the
clock tower thing yeah that happened
right
yeah we had one there was there was a
guy
i had we had a serial killer in
poughkeepsie where i went to school and
uh this guy kendall francois i remember
seeing him
he was this overweight um
guy huge guy i remember seeing him late
night at the at the mcdonald's or the
dunkin donuts or something and um
he was just a presence because he was so
big and uh
it was quiet and it turns out like it
what the year i left they found yeah
crazy nine bodies anyway where do you go
from there um
have you played uh you but you've played
some of these guys you've played some
real psychopaths
yeah played some yeah what
i'm thinking get out uh a guy like that
he's a psychopath for sure yeah do you
is that do you enjoy that what is
i rarely
again it's just that's just fun playing
stuff yeah i mean for me it was another
it was another imovie you know because
it was blind in that movie that's right
him get out so it was i had to do some
stuff that i did in oh brother where he
was blind as well so i had to do a
couple of things that
i i
where you're you're not looking
yeah you're looking at you're looking
around and stuff so it was another
another imovie for me but it was fun it
was fun trying to do it being able to
play a different kind of blind guy i
yeah i remember practicing that i did a
play called butterflies for free and
right sure yeah i remember practicing
all the time i i was dating this girl to
drive her nuts she was like we're just
having dinner can you just look at your
food you know trying to put them in my
mouth
uh
were you um when you're falling in love
with acting in in college are you
thinking
were your parents more pragmatic did you
have was that a tough conversation to
have to say to them hey you know i think
i might want to make a career out of
this or were they like i was shocked
because my dad was straight construction
supervisor
wyoming cowboy
you know you know we would go to
wyoming and
yellowstone every year for vacation
he was a straight construction guy uh
and when i when i switched majors in 73
70 or some time around there
um he was incredibly supportive ah
he's like uh because i don't think he
got to do what he wanted to do
which is what
not be a
a painter you know i mean he started out
doing construction painting
and kind of
taught himself engineering and and went
to
uh he was one of those self-made guys
you know who finally made it to the top
of of his profession
without going to college and that can't
happen
anymore um
but he was also the guy who
went
in 1939 went and went into the army but
he went into the cavalry there was still
the cavalry no [ __ ] framed his own horse
he was in uh you know a unit that uh
trained out west with like bugles and
like sabers and the whole thing oh my
god and they disbanded it in 41 he had
to take his horse which he loved which
loved him
and put him on a train to you know dog
food land oh no it was just
heartbreaking so they disbanded it
before we entered the war then so he
didn't see any yeah and then they threw
him into tanks
oh my god
him into a tank
he became a tank commander and went
through the battle of the bulge in 44.
oh he did jesus god which was brutal
right because yeah i mean the survival
rate in a tank if anything were to it
was like
zero the only time he talked about it he
said if i went this way i'm dead if i go
this way i'm dead i happen to go that
way
you know oh my god the constant
pressure must can you imagine you yeah
now sitting sitting in you know the
bulge with potato vodka as your only
thing in a tin can waiting for a panzer
to blow you up that was so without i'm
saying that he didn't get to do what he
wanted to do when he was a young man he
was that
so i think he really
dug it that i found something that i
really liked
uh and and when he finally came
to see me in something in new york
because his the office that he worked
for was in new york
he he saw me in um journey's end 1920s
world war one play where i had
straight cockney
you know
and he saw me do that and he was like
oh i get it
i get you're not you think no not me i
like doing other guys so he got it at
that point and he never did get to see
me on film
or tv because he passed before that but
he got it when he saw that how cool how
that must have been
i mean all the things all the
accomplishments the accolades you get
and that must have been it that must
have been that was it that was it he's
like he saw me in this off-broadway play
and was just okay i get it
right how did you do the cockney was it
something that you just used your you
just listened to you know like you say
some people have an ear and i and i
think i've got one enough to i've seen
enough
monty python and the beatles and
everybody else that i i could construct
what i needed to get out of that yeah
yeah um
steve what what what haven't you done
you've done all the i'm talking about
what do you want to do what's something
that like oh you know i've never gone to
do you ever find yourself watching
something and think oh i've never gotten
to do that i'd like to do that
what i tell a lot of young actors is
they're not going to stop making tv
or film so don't worry about not
getting something it's it's
you don't get an audition you didn't
have the job in the first place you're
just trying to get one
so don't don't worry about not getting
you didn't not get it you never had it
right right
you just didn't get the thing you
weren't supposed to get announced yeah
there's always going to be something
else yeah
and once i adopted that
it was like okay
so
to answer your question there's always
going to be something else interesting
coming up yeah
and do i have to do my lear i don't have
to
if if it came about would i do it i
don't know i'm pretty lazy oh you are
i i i am oh i'm the laziest actor on the
planet
is that why i mean you kind of said this
when uh you were talking about doing
character roles it is
just in terms of memorizing and putting
in time it is a lot easier in that sense
to do those
you know when you're finally doing a
show it's a yeah it's an everyday thing
doing barry was you know like that
it's hard work doing that everyday i
would love to see your lear c stephen i
would look i would love to see that now
um
maybe it will come down
hopefully i'll end up doing some more
shakes but i felt it kind of went in a
circle when
joel uh cohen is doing macbeth oh really
we did the tragedy of
the scottish people yeah yeah
is it bad luck to say it outside it you
can say it outside of theater right you
can say it outside so
we we did that and we had just
gotten to almost done with it and and it
was covered oh my god oh they were
filming it i didn't know that they did
that yeah wow so who did you play in
that
uh i got to be porter ah
which is tremendous little role but it's
a great fun role and and we we just had
a blast with it because he shot it like
a play doing long long takes ah two long
takes and we only did it on stages no
outside stuff just on stages so it was
like walking into a 40s production you
know they build these oh wow
oh castles and stuff it was awesome oh
wow black and white
no kidding how cool
so sound stages in la they do them on
the big screen yeah yeah paramount yeah
wow wow who else
who else is in it steven uh oh just a
plethora of people um
um oh it's francis
yeah frank uh frannie mcdormand is lady
macbeth
there's uh it's a lot of great english
actors that uh i knew their names when
we were doing it yeah oh stephen i can't
wait i
that's uh but but uh
gleason is doing it uh uh
yeah uh just um amazing he's so cool
just so today did they finish shooting
or they're gonna have to pick it up they
ended up being able to finish it said a
week to go so they brought a couple of
actors over during cove who did the
whole thing and they finished it so it
should be out in 21 sometime okay oh wow
so hey there's another thing to look
forward to in 2021
yeah i'm i'm looking forward to the
vaccine
macbeth
and and our masters of the universe oh
that
that's right
what an idiot that's right it was right
there yeah that's right
yes who are you playing again
i'm playing cringer cringer right it's
you know it's funny uh somebody
mentioned
how did you do it how did it sound
cringer and battle cat yes
it really takes advantage of your range
yes from 3 to 99. yeah
yeah yeah yet another director who um
who loves you who i know kevin smith
wrote so kevin did masters in the
universe and he wrote a i i read that he
wrote a part for you in jersey girl he
wrote that part for you he did he did he
was fantastic and he let me play with it
and and and and really
what i wanted to do with it it was very
generous yeah yeah i love i love how
much he loves actors he's one of those
guys that just
he has such like child-like enthusiasm
for
actors yeah yeah uh that's right he's on
the project that he really digs he
really i guess dug that as a kid so
that's awesome
so you were you were a little out of you
were a little older
yeah
yeah i wasn't i was the per i was the
age and i just okay but i was never into
it i don't know why that was not my
thing i i liked transformers there i
loved certain cartoons oh in fact i i
got to interview um
this guy eric i'm almost a kid that he's
my age eric bowser who is a philip do
you know him i don't know
eric loves you eric is this huge uh
voice over actor um he's playing bugs
bunny uh so many looney tunes characters
oh brilliant people don't know how
brilliant real voice actors are
i mean i'm lucky to get in as a
character actor but these guys are
brilliant well they do anything he he
really is gifted he's like a virtuoso
he's the way i feel about you as an
actor and um
but he was so excited that that i was
going to be talking to you because i
think for voice guys they would
they would rank you among you know among
them yeah but i'm not i i i really
respect what they do the fact that they
can just pull it out you know he would
go like this
sometimes but i i can't pull out the
amount of stuff they can pull out
on this on the moment
and neither can i what i found amazing
was that he could go he could have a
dialogue between bugs and daffy
without
missing a beat without having to
re-center what that's what mike did mike
did uh beavis and butthead right
and you know without even missing a b he
would do the same thing for uh king of
the hill as well wow
and uh
um
boomhauer boomhauer and and somebody
asked you to do your character uh you
you did a couple i know you did a couple
on i did i did bill um the the not
really bright army barber
and i did uh hank's boss mr strickland
oh yeah i did uh topsy who was like an
88 89 year old friend of
of uh
his dad of hank's dad which is done by
terry huss the brilliant oh i love toby
huss
how did boomhauer go but it was
boomhauer kind of
was like boomhauer you couldn't
understand what he said
oh yeah
oh yeah but mike could do go from hey
to to crazy boomhauer in without
stopping as well and i think you can do
that with beavis and bud head
some people can do it i can't yeah he he
did it i remember seeing him do it with
beaverson but had the day i was the day
i met him the day i think you were there
stephen had you just left in austin when
we were doing idiocracy
yeah you had shot the day before so i
got to see some of your stuff uh
ordering the court yeah
the judge stuff but then well my
favorite thing about the judge in that
was that he was just terrified so my my
entrance was
was just against the wall
that's my favorite thing to do you ain't
kind of like wolverine-ish hair oh
completely wolverine
yeah the mutton challenge
the size of twice three times the size
of a gavel yes that's right that's right
i don't know if you remember this a year
earlier whenever we did dodgeball which
i think was about a year and a half or
so earlier i had asked you to do um
milton if you would do milton on my
answering machine
do you remember this
i do and you were so sweet but you took
it and you had it for like an hour
because you you felt like you had and
you really i remember you coming out um
kind of shaking your head and like yeah
i don't know if i got it right i don't
know if i did it well enough and it was
so good it was like great um
but then
it's always weird when you do something
five or ten years after i bet
it's you know people have have that yeah
you have a vague memory of it but that's
true although you were able to access
the king of the hill character that you
were asked to do well i love bill
one of my favorite guys
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
[Music]
i'm trying to think of other dodgeball
memories that um you know we talked
about dodgeball so much just because i
was just talking to vince on the show
and
uh
and so it's come up a lot lately but
i just remember laughing so much on that
set and um and there were such different
personalities you know uh
i just had so much fun
i don't know if he had done a lot of a
lot of stuff before that uh because i
remember him telling me he was working
on his pirate
all the time yes yes yeah and so
it was really fun to watch him try out
stuff just sitting there
being pirate pirates
it's funny as absurd as that character
is allen's one of those acts i mean like
you i mean allen's a theater guy he's
he's such a committed serious actor that
um
he and that's why that that's why you're
all so good in that you you it's you
make those ridiculous characters so
grounded um thank you oh do you remember
this stephen do you remember the um do
you remember the extras that they got
when we were playing dodgeball they
filled the stadium the stands with a lot
of
inmates who had just gotten out of
prison yes yeah yes
oh they were they were great they were
such characters and
and they were there for um i don't think
they were paying them much and they were
uh they were they would have to keep
them all there during the setups and
they would start getting a little
restless and
so i forget who it was you somebody came
out like the second id or maybe the
first and they started
they started playing like um
that like a hype map they were like uh
host it was like they were a host of
something they were they were
having trivia contests and they were
giving away dvds um it was like somebody
doing a warm-up for for a sitcom that's
what it was yeah and and and there was
but it was a tough audience i mean like
literally tough
in many cases and um i remember one day
they they i had heard that they uh had
to
clear out where they were holding them
and they call it extras holding because
they found uh needles a bunch of needles
um and there were things like that so if
you look at that movie really closely
and sometimes i'd catch the eyes of
somebody with you know like
crazy face tattoos or like
just menacing looking two real
characters they were well they were
menacing looking yeah it was great for
the film yeah well buddy it's so nice to
see i just have a light there's a
lightning round
questions a couple of questions
but you know i'm not that bright no i
know i know
so
so i'm going to so we got to take a
really slow all good
good
um okay what is your most commonly used
emoji
thumbs up thumbs up yeah
yeah useful probably yeah um
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play
golf you go off a lot
i do i'm very very very very very bad
that's what you said i love it i love
being outside walking with friends
that's the thing yeah i got to do with
you i invited myself last time and i'm i
i i'd love to we'll get you yeah i'd
love it
um if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life what would it be
corn chips oh yeah for like fritos
now trader joe's oh yeah okay oh yeah
that's the bigger
delicious
what did you what's your favorite movie
sequel of all time steve you were in
robocop three
godfather two
godfather two yeah
what is your go-to karaoke song
are you laughing because you don't sing
karaoke
i don't think karaoke but if it would be
something it would be probably anything
from the british invasion in the 60s oh
okay like like the kings for the beatles
or something yeah something simple yeah
do you remember who your first celebrity
crush was
barbara eden oh yeah a dream of genie
yeah you dreamed you dreamed of genie i
dreamed manny dream
if you had to get a tattoo do you have a
tattoo
uh i have one right now just because i
was i was doing a movie where i played
an old biker oh no way
here's my oh wow
there's my shark oh cool yeah it's
steve's showing his forearm it's a shark
it's a
it's a shark
yeah for sure oh cool and i also uh up
here i had a oh on his neck his
collarbone
yeah it was um was it a pegasus sector
with a side but the side got washed off
oh yeah well done good
those aren't they're good they're really
good
what was that with alice and janie the
one you did with her yeah yeah yeah okay
we just finished it up
uh which did you shot it in l.a
got it nellie uh see me yeah oh great um
okay and if you got one permanently
steve what would you do what do you
think you would
get um something like my wife got was
she got one on her
on her ankle that says
established 1963 which is when she was
born that's funny something like that
something small yeah
but in that vein oh that's cool um okay
what and what is your favorite fruit if
you could have you pick a fruit a nice
ripe piece of
pear
pear
yeah
there's nothing better than a perfectly
ripe pear
eating it
yeah
who do you like that pair when it's a
little softer just kind of has a bite to
it
the
medium soft medium soft
juices flowing yeah
that's funny to sound like juices
flowing the juices they must flow um
who who would you want to play you in a
biopic this the steven root story oh my
god
oh there should never be one of those
that's exactly what steven root would
say in the movie
um
wayne duval
who is a cousin of
the other people oh yeah
he's an actor in new york he's a really
good actor
okay cool uh hear that wayne i hope
you're listening because you were just
cast you were officially cast
um what's your favorite do who's your
favorite simpsons characters have you
ever done a voice on the simpsons
i just did this year for the first time
no kidding
for the first time i finally got to do
it because you know king of the hill and
simpsons they were they were like
you couldn't
cross me right but weren't you as i
recall i remember you guys because when
i was doing alvin and the chipmunks you
guys were always right there at the fox
yeah we are all in the same place all in
the same place yeah
you wouldn't let us play on each other's
show but now that it's been on 800 years
they don't
work oh like doing this year which is
great great
character
probably anything hank azaria does
because he's really
well and which do you prefer dogs or
cats
oh dogs yeah you have one
uh we we had to we now have one
uh but we will be getting another little
one because
you can travel with the little ones you
know and when we can travel again we'd
like to be able to travel with you know
einstein
yeah i hear you um uh the beatles were
the rolling stones oh
beetles uh
but but
the rolling stones are the greatest rock
and roll band
now how do you feel here they're still
here they're still trout touring have
you seen them play oh okay
uh last time i saw them play
was in the 80s and they were great yeah
um
but yeah live yeah that's the last time
live
um
and uh seinfeld are friends if they were
both on which one do you watch
um um i watched seinfeld
me too watch time my my kid is a huge
friends person
you know i this is a an embarrassing
thing to admit i've never really
and i know it's great it's a classic for
a reason i've never
really seen several in a row episodes of
friends i don't know the show that well
um
friends uh
we as a cast
at news radio the first we were doing it
went
to see the show to see a taping oh cool
because we were nobody
you know we weren't on the air yet we
just wanted to go see
see friends um
and
there
their timing was so
astonishing at least in the first few
seasons of that show that it was really
a joy to watch
well i think i could say that about your
show as well about news radio was but
you had you had the same
rehearsal schedule that all multi-cams
have right like was there anything what
what was the secret ingredient do you
guys just work your asses off to perfect
that time yeah
well it was it was hard because
we got scripts late
um
the last couple of seasons we barely got
them
um
but it was okay with us because by then
we knew we knew what to do
uh the first couple of seasons we worked
really
really hard on 40 page scripts that you
know we would shoot a lot of stuff that
wasn't
you knew wasn't going to get on really
and that got to be frustrating so we had
the streamlined process after that yeah
and stephen when you're um
when you're stoned do you get very
snacky when you're stoned
you know what i don't really do it
anymore because oh yeah
it got to be
when pot got to be just super strong
in the 80s and 90s
it just made me paranoid so i don't
really do anymore i i kind of longed for
the
shitty 70s spot where you could
smoke a whole joint of it and have a
nice night yeah i wonder if they could
if they still make a version if they
have figured out a way to
you know manufacture that
an old-time old-time bud would be great
i'd love to shitty schwag i bet they
make it um
buddy
what's that nixon stems yes yeah uh
what are to think about about death a
lot about leaving
earth and and
i think about legacy and all that kind
of stuff um
but and it's always been it's always
hard for me to ask people because it's
such a especially in a lightning round
because it's obviously such
it's not a lightning round question but
i'm wondering if um
you could think of two adjectives that
you'd want people to use to describe you
nice
and
professional well i can attest to both
uh
and that's truly one of the nicest and
and one of my favorite actors thank uh
thank you steven for doing this oh it's
right back to you i your your work has
always astonished me and and your your
comic timing is genius and you are a
genius so i'm happy to be on with you
and it's venmo we
we determine we i forget how much
exactly we said i would pay you but it's
i do have venmo so i'll just shoot that
over to you
um when we're done with this that's a
given isn't it yeah yeah
you'll be paying me
well this is really going to make your
career so you're welcome
love the show love you
likewise and looking forward to the time
when i can actually when i can see we
can get it we can get a drink
yeah we'll do it all right we'll do it
virtually
yes big squeeze
so
yes it happened that just happened well
no that's a little bit too much that's
rupee dog comic
it's you know
we talk about having like um anchor
words for impressions and i guess
stapler stapler it'd have to be okay
yeah or burn down the building i'm gonna
burn down he's so good in that and
received my paycheck oh yeah
i love that movie that's one of those
movies it's on and
he talks to himself but that type of
person is so familiar to me i had never
seen a character like that in
on screen before i never seen that
captured so
uh specifically on screen
and yet it's such a familiar type of
person you know yeah i do that like kind
of
neutered but but like wanted to show
strength and
you know it's just i mean he's it's a
cartoon it's like yeah a groundbreaking
cartoon it's an absurd character
but he's so committed
to it that it feels real in that movie i
know it's such a it's such a strange
thing because it is a ridiculous
character that seems real he he does a
thing in that that
to your point that kind of fills it out
that makes it more real where he um
he kind of it's not just that he's
talking to himself he's
he's so afraid to express himself that
he um he has this whole internal
uh dialogue with himself almost like you
can see him he kind of like
moves his lips like to himself i was
told i could listen to the music
it's like
and apparently
uh mike judge just had him like go on
you just had him like well you know he'd
be like um okay you can uh just add lips
that's what we talked about it's amazing
that cake scene i know he was like um i
hadn't received any and see i know it's
brilliant brilliant and steven's so
self-deprecating i'm sure you noticed
everything is like he's very humble and
so i've heard him say things like oh i'm
not an improviser i mean like you or
like vince that you guys are yeah but he
i mean like there's no denying that he's
and i saw him do such great stuff like
that in dodgeball but yeah that cake
scene is just a perfect example he's
very complimentary of you he is that
means a lot because i you know how much
i look up to him yeah i mean a lot yeah
it was cool but you do i mean you do
have a great year i but i think he does
too oh god i mean and then he'll you
know you're talking about eric bowes and
these voice over actors uh who is
i truly believe a genius but stephen
when he then was talking about his
characters on king of the hill like he's
right up there
uh he says otherwise and i i think he's
probably right i i think he's right to
put eric bowes in a different kind of
well because that ability to switch back
and forth that's like i know i'm
verified i know i was trying to prompt
him to do the voice sometimes i noticed
yeah yeah
like i did all those years ago when we
worked together and i asked him to do my
outgoing message that was my outgoing
message for so long until what trump um
it was my judge doing beavers and by dad
so it would um stevens was the milton
was something like yes um you you
reached justin's phone in looking for my
stapler you know something like that it
was really funny i'm really proud of
that one it's amazing how long his
career has lasted i know he talked about
that just lasting as it doesn't sound
like a compliment to say this about
someone but i think it really is oh yeah
in that profession hanging in there just
lasting that long and being called a
journeyman i know or saying hanging in
there
says so much i know it's so few people
last that long in that career and the
parts start becoming
more
you know fewer and further between think
about when you were starting my god in
the late 90s all the people that you
would see at auditions oh man and that
were doing really well at the time
how few of them are still working the
people that are still around in this
peer group are like francis mcdormand
it's like really right few people it
takes something big to to sustain
uh you for more years it takes like for
in my case something like dodgeball or
i'm thinking like aaron paul like aaron
was one of those guys that you know i'd
see out auditions all the time and it
took
break i remember he got breaking bad it
takes a thing that's the thing that
keeps people in it i would say i would
agree with you for most people but i
think
uh in his case the ability to do a ton
of rights that's really really well yes
and i think very few people can do a ton
of things really really well to the
point where they're not getting replaced
right exactly you know other people most
people get replaced that's true that
business especially when you look i
don't know how to say this without
sounding insulting but when you look
like a very normal person stephen looks
like a guy if you saw stephen on the
street
you know you wouldn't necessarily think
like there's like a movie act not that
if you saw me on the street i know i
know i know but like on my look or
whatever i was lucky because i you're
luke my luke is more specific it's more
specific it's more like i looked young
that gave me a little boost i started
playing a lot of younger you still look
young yeah well
i look like weird like old young but um
you know and like and same with aaron i
mean there but stephen there's something
about a guy like that who
if you're not a brilliant actor what is
philip seymour hoffman too exactly not
but name
you know three more john c reilly yeah
well okay right i also like how he said
in order to play many different types of
parts and not get typecast i'm
paraphrasing but he said something like
you have to educate the casting
directors that was such a subtle subtly
confident way of making that point he's
putting himself in this position
yeah that's true you could misinterpret
that as like a braggy thing to say but i
think it's just confidence it's like
understated confidence yeah and i
noticed that about all the great
auditions i love watching audition take
like good auditions like steve carell
auditioned for anchorman or robert de
niro reading for the first godfather
which he
amazingly didn't get but there's
they all have this thing in common which
is that which is like they own
the room and i remember hearing stories
about jim caviezel that he went into the
pearl harbor the pearl harbor audition
and he was uh i guess jerry brockheimer
and michael bay would like to chit chat
hey and they kind of like size people up
and it takes you out of it they ask you
where you're from oh how long you've
been out here there's just like chit
chat and then go into the scene and the
scene could be you know whatever it is
jim caviezel would go in and they'd try
to chit chat and he would ignore them
and he would just say where do you want
me right here you rolling good you know
it was like that and just like i'm in
control it's balls balls for a guy who
hadn't that's how he got he got thin red
line because that he did that with
terence malik apparently where do you
want me yeah he would just i mean 99.9
percent of people would think i need
these people to like me of course that's
the psychology of course that confidence
that like and steven's certainly not
douche i don't know i keep saying steven
well i noticed that for the first half
of the interview you you called him
stephen and then as you became more
familiar with them you started calling
steve really yeah steve steve i'm trying
to think when i when i see him when i
come hey i call him like buddy or baby
or stuff um but um
yeah steve he has that confidence
without being and that's that it comes
up sometimes on the show like uh it's
it's a rare combination of that type of
confidence that level confidence without
arrogance right right yeah that's rare
i love what he said about his dad and
it's so cool i know supportive i know
he was
um and and and just the perspective
that someone like that must have you
know to be
he was in
um and to just be so grateful that
your son has found something that they
love and and to i know and to not let
your own hang-ups or your own
uncertainties about something
uh scare you uh you know and and
to limit your your um wishes for your
son for your kids to be that open-minded
yeah coming from such a different place
such a different generation but again
i'm i'm assuming um that his father's
open-mindedness even though he did such
a different he had such a different life
path yeah than his son
uh i'm sure he passed down that
open-mindedness to his son sounds like
you know another interesting thing about
that generational
transference
is is the situation that his dad
was familiar with that high stakes that
the pressure can you i mean i can't
imagine that level of stress
in a panzer panzer tank and you know not
knowing if just drinking vodka not
knowing if the next turn is going to be
your last because it'd be like like you
said you're in a tin can just waiting
get blown up i mean i cannot conceive of
that level of anxiety and so for
for someone to experience that in a
lifetime and just one lifetime removed
from that to to produce
a an offspring a a
an heir you know who is like
who ends up being so kind of chill and
happy and doing all this great work and
like entertaining but i don't know
there's something really uh
got overwhelming about that it is yeah i
was thinking about um it reminded me of
the other day i was hanging out with my
neighbor uh shout out to mick and linda
up at the up at the lake and
and they had friends over
um two of whom were
uh from nearby it doesn't matter even
though but it matters to me because they
had these great boston accents and and
they were saying we were talking i asked
them what their son did their son was
they said oh my son's about your age 41
i think and um
and i said oh what does he do which i'm
always a little bit like i don't know
why that's the first thing
i ask about somebody what does he do
it's a lot of people i know i know but
it helps to find your opinion of them
well they said it was interesting um
their response they said not much
he doesn't do much um but he's kind of a
vagabond but they didn't say it in like
uh an embarrassed or a self-deprecating
way they just said it like that's what
he does he doesn't do much he lives on
him
he lives i think he lives in a trailer
uh in in upstate new york and and i said
oh but they said it kind of with almost
with cheer with like good pride with
pride
yeah and i said and i never heard that
response said that way it sounded like
he really didn't do anything and they
said well you know he knows a lot of um
wealthy people and like they like him
and they kind of just like he just like
lives in a little thing and um i said
well is he happy and they said
very well and i was like god how cool to
like have that perspective we're from
such a different place i know let's read
a letter oh another stephen
this is from stephen brown maybe he
likes to be called steve or they like to
be called steve or or
brown dog
yeah
you never know um
uh or brown eyed guy
okay you're my brown okay subject you're
my brown guy okay so i got to explain
the joke yeah yeah oh boy okay so
oh brown okay
subject i have an idea hi justin my name
is steven
i recently came across your podcast by
chance considering i never listened to
podcasts of any kind really and i found
myself listening to you more than i
listened to actual music while i worked
these past few days wow
that's cool that we beat music
uh it's really i just have to be a
competition it's really opened my eyes
to how fast life can go by
uh thank you steven like you i am also a
movie lover but i find myself comparing
my age to whoever is in the movie i'm
watching yeah i do that too i watched
your movie accepted recently and i
literally said out loud
and he's quoting himself wow i'm older
than justin was when he was in the movie
that's my impression of stephen not
knowing anything about how he talks um
it definitely made me think i'll be 30
in august whoa
lucky and i know that may seem like
nothing to you but it's definitely going
to be a milestone my question to you is
when you turned 30 what were some of the
things you think you'd accomplish or do
and now that you're over 40
what were some of the things you wish
you did what a great question um
and i'm not saying you still can't do
whatever those things are are you
laughing about your stuff yeah my
stomach is yeah my digestive system has
gotten a little worse i'll tell you that
steven since i was 30
um
i didn't have those kind of ambitions i
know as much as i thought about time
i didn't think about the future like
that like i know a lot of people do like
oh by the time i turn 30 i'm gonna do
that i didn't have some concrete can i
weigh in yeah yeah um and far be it for
me to tell you what your own goals were
but i would say that because you have
such a and you used to have more of this
uh a peter pan complex i think you were
always if anything afraid of making
those types of plans like your adult
plans yes you know settling down and
yeah having a house and a mortgage and a
you know i think that always
was something you avoided well because
there was a degree of uh and i'm sure
it's a death
fixation as at the root of this but it
was there was a degree of finality to it
and to me life just seemed
too open to to close if that makes sense
um
and i'm not saying that's the right way
to look at things i don't think it is
actually i don't know i don't think
that's very healthy and certainly
prevented um
me from doing certain things but to that
point i also thought
i'm sure 40 seems so distant that i'm
sure if i thought about it at that age
at your age stephen i would have thought
yeah i'm going to have a family by the
time i'm 40. it's crazy you're almost 50
now okay so
that remember when you were kids
almost 50. well the idea of being um 50
oh it was like that you were yeah is
that why then it's right around the
corner for you get out of here you know
your birthday is uh tomorrow by the way
happy early birthday oh
thanks i just realized that i just
realized what day it was yeah you know
and this is also defeat i know this too
because um
we were raised in a household that was
very aware my dad was very into saints
the feast day of uh saints
and um i know that june 1st is the feast
of saint justin
and i know that because uh that's why
i'm named justin i was born the next day
i was almost named
cuthbert yep have we talked about this
we have yeah yeah i was almost sebastian
oh that's cool
it's a little pretentious maybe but it's
a great name i think it's pretentious to
say the whole thing but uh sebastian now
also now crab like that sebastian and
little oh right yeah
um
sebastian or i think also
ryan phillippe oh yeah wait what oh yes
oh yes oh yeah sebastian uh future guest
and star of lady the manager coming on
september 17th um back to the letter
where were we uh so i hope that answered
your question steven uh
and what were some of the things you
wish you did yeah so i didn't really
have that like oh i wish i whatever you
did a lot of fun things i did i i really
i feel pretty accomplished not
accomplished career-wise but in life for
those years uh okay and back to stephen
and i'm not saying you still can't do
whatever those things were but the clock
is ticking it sure is thanks stephen
okay i just hope i can find more purpose
and as of right now i'm kind of going
day by day well that's good but
listening to your podcasts gives me
insight on the matter and i'm truly
grateful to have lived in the same
lifetime as justin long god what didn't
what a nice thing to say
thanks stephen um
unless he was being sarcastic
it doesn't sound it doesn't at all
why can't i just take a compliment
uh guilt yeah i guess so shame yep okay
yes
they shouldn't have killed you often
jeepers creepers i think
man also please talk to vince about
getting a dodgeball two script together
thanks oh that's appropriate for this
episode it sure is yeah man that'd be
fun
it's come up it really kind of seems
like a no-brainer
well i don't know those movies are like
it's
when you see a cast that many years
later and they're like i don't know
they all look pretty good they do you
know okay back to steven keep doing what
you're doing justin you're great oh and
your brother is great too in case you're
actually reading this i know you
probably get a ton of emails oh i'm glad
we are reading it i hope he means me
yeah i'm david he doesn't know damian i
don't think but he didn't specify so he
might have maintained it sincerely
stephen t brown stephen t brown thank
you
brown yeah what a nice name um if i had
a name like steven brown with a pretty
common first name
i would use my middle initial two yeah
that's michael j fox
yes
yeah michael b jordan yes exactly um
that's a better example well because he
did it too because michael jordan of
course
now was he born before michael jordan
was a star
uh good question was like were his
parents
conscientious of that i bet he was i bet
he was before yeah how old is michael b
jordan he's got to be in his 30s he's
got to be
michael bakari is his middle name that's
not funny that's not what i meant um
he's 34. he was born in 1987. so
jordan
had already ascended
somewhat i mean he was he wasn't he was
definitely in the nba he was but he
wasn't 84 he wasn't michael jordan yeah
he was rookie of the year he won the the
dunk contest he did some [ __ ] but by
then so you're suggesting he's a big
star tim after michael jordan
i'm suggesting that they were aware uh
enough of it to be like oh this might be
kind of a cool homage that maybe you're
right have you ever met another
christian long
christian be long uh no i haven't are
you trying to think if this is
interesting enough to include i know
it's not oh um all right
anyway thank you i hope stephen brown
enjoyed that last i'm sure he's ten
minutes of his life but thank you
stephen for your letter that really was
um
it was very nice to hear thank you for
i'm taking the compliments um because my
friend dustria shout out in fayetteville
arkansas she she's
taught me how important that is
and thank you to our guest steven root
the legendary actor and if you guys
would like to write in our email address
is life is short at wondery.com and in
the letter you can say whatever you want
you can also give shout outs if you want
and you can ask would you rather oh yeah
you could do whatever you want uh you
know you've become obsessed with with um
shout outs oh i like it it's a nice but
lately it's like it's become a
compulsion i think for you oh really
yeah and now i'm struggling to come up
with one a shout out to somebody oh todd
chandler
you've
shouted him out several times there's no
rules shout out rules that you can only
shout out someone once you're um he
helped me with your father your co-dad
yes my my
foster parent uh he took care of the
parent the turtles for the last couple
of months and i'm happy to report that
they're safe and sound back in the lake
from whence they came and we'll talk to
you all next week okay
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and co-produced by
you christian long it is also produced
by megan the monaco yes
the senior producer is michelle miesh
lans and who i always forget who's the
audio engineer i'm just kidding
sergio enriquez and executive producer
marshall louie for wandery are you sure
wait no fundery oh yeah wondering
[Music]
hi this is army barber william fontaine
de la turdo trev saying
so long from the justin long
broadcast no it's it's it's pod it's pod
okay
signing off from the justin long broad
pod
okay that's that's good enough and they
did
mr dauterive friend
milton thing
i was told justin was long
that's a lie
you